as we've discussed in other videos the
federal bureaucracy is a huge part of
the us government sometimes even called
the fourth branch it has more than two
million employees who work in various
agencies dedicated to implementing the
law so the bureaucracy has a lot of
discretion to decide how best to achieve
a policy goal but the sheer size of the
bureaucracy along with its independence
can make it difficult to monitor what
happens when a bureaucratic agency fails
to carry out its mission or deviates
from the letter or the intent of a law
what can the other branches do to keep
it accountable let's use a real example
to make things a bit more concrete in
2014 a whistleblower came forward
reporting that a hospital in the
department of veterans affairs was
deceiving federal regulators about how
long veterans were waiting to receive
health care because officials at the va
got pay bonuses based on ensuring that
patients had short wait times for
medical care they were falsifying
electronic records to keep wait times
within those acceptable guidelines in
reality though the average wait time for
medical care was greater than 100 days
and dozens of veterans died while
waiting for delayed appointments now
this is a pretty complex story so i'm
just giving you the broad strokes here
but for our purposes what you need to
know is this was a case of very serious
mismanagement in a bureaucratic agency
so now let's think about what the other
branches of government could do using
their formal and informal powers in
response to this situation i encourage
you to pause the video here and see if
you can list at least one action that
the executive branch congress or the
judicial branch could take
ready
go
okay so let's go through some of the
actions that the other branches did take
in response to the va scandal and you
can check to see if you came up with any
of them so what steps did the executive
take remember that the bureaucracy
itself is under the executive branch so
first we saw internal investigations
from the secretary of veterans affairs
eric shinseki the va used its rulemaking
authority to abandon the unrealistic
wait time goal in order to remove that
perverse incentive it was within the
power of barack obama who was president
at the time to fire the cabinet
secretary but instead shinseki resigned
then the president used his nomination
power to replace him with a new va
secretary bob mcdonald obama also
introduced a number of executive actions
to address the problem including
establishing an independent
accountability review board a board of
physicians to advise the secretary a
plan to upgrade the electronic health
record system and protections for
whistleblowers what steps did congress
take first congress used its oversight
power to call hearings investigating
what was going on at the va they
subpoenaed secretary shinseki to testify
they also passed reform measures using
their law making powers and the power of
the purse to fix the larger problems at
the va funding a 16 billion dollar plan
to hire more doctors and nurses
upgrade facilities and allow veterans to
see private doctors if necessary and as
part of this reform congress included
legislation that made it easier to hold
va officials accountable for misconduct
congress also used its power to approve
presidential nominations by confirming
the new va secretary
the judicial branch for its part
reviewed the constitutionality of the
new rules holding va employees
accountable the federal court system
heard a case about whether it was
constitutional to fire civil servants
who weren't appointed without giving
them a chance to appeal the courts ruled
that that was unconstitutional so in
2017 congress passed a new bill adding a
grievance process for civil servants
which president trump then signed into
law
so it's been a few years since the va
scandal so how are things doing did the
reform measures work in 2015 the new
york times reported that only three
people had been fired as a response to
the scandal despite bob mcdonald's
public statements that 60 employees had
been fired in 2019 deborah draper the
health care director at the government
accountability office told the house
veterans affairs committee that although
the va had made progress in wait times
and scheduling there was still room for
improvement she said that the va's new
system was still not accurately
recording patient wait times and that
veterans might still wait up to 70 days
for an appointment even though the va
was reporting a much shorter delay on
the positive side the va completed one
million more appointments for veterans
in 2018 than in 2017 showing that access
to care for veterans had definitely
improved so what do you think were the
other branches of government able to
hold the va accountable if you had to
solve this problem either as a member of
congress a judge or the president what
other steps could you take